Okay, is your person a man?
You know, they might
be gender non-binary.
Okay. You know what, you go.
Okay. Is your person a cis,
straight, white,
probably skinny-dicked cog
in the machine
of the suffocating,
heteronormative, patriarchal,
misogynistic, value-driven,
Judeo-Christian,
military-industrial
complex?
I mean, I don't think
he's white, but I'm not sure.
I shouldn't assume.
Yeah, better not to assume.
Yeah. Okay.
Is your person wearing
any sort of accessory?
I mean, are we including
procedures
meant to protect the gender
nonconforming from hate speech
based solely on appearance?
I just meant like earrings.
Oh, no.
Okay. Yes, baby, two down.
Here we go.
Okay, is your person
Hispanic?
Okay, you know what?
I think we're good here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I feel good.
I think we're good.
I feel good. I had Max.
I had Anita, so good game.
I'll see you later.
Bye, bitch.
Bye.